hey what's up you guys this is the daily
denne denne and we are coming to you
from day two of comic-con here in San
Diego you know they say this every year
but comic-con is madness I thought it
was a brilliant idea to be in the middle
of it all the belly of the beast right
here at the Convention Center for all
the antics and more check it out
[Music]
I'm inside the belly of the beast the
eye of the storm the actual Convention
Center here at San Diego comic-con now
last year I stuck out like a sore thumb
because I didn't have a costume I'm
getting one step closer trying to blend
in my yabba-dabba-do right here Fred
Flintstone how's it going it's going
fantastic yeah how are you staying cool
in this costume
I'm not ready I've accepted my life
these costumes are so elaborate you guys
make these yourself
crushed it looks so so good are you hot
though cuz it's San Diego I'm sweating
just wearing this jacket yeah yeah right
what number comic-con is this for you
one really yeah it's my first one ever
you seem like an expert no I mean I hit
it hard like I'd like if I'm gonna go
it's gonna be number one and do four
costumes like it's best as I can this is
number three and I'm real basic I have
to talk about these costumes right here
because I'm also a little confused like
is this Captain America no these are his
girlfriend's uh we're the rest my
Justice League at I knew it I sense the
villain was in my presence miss Harley
Quinn how you doing you look good you
know I love that you went comic book
Harley by the way right I do like the
comics right there was a year where it
was just nothing but Harley Quinn's from
the Suicide Squad right all right well
don't go cause any trouble Harley no
promises
whoa oh my god I am surrounded by DC
villains Joker good day as you could
tell it's a lot of fun down there also
little crazy and date three a little
smelly but we survived all right guys
joining me now is our resident TV expert
Miss Lee and Aguilar how you holding up
you've been busy I've been busy but you
know I'm feeling stellar yeah I see what
you did there
cuz you've been talking to some
intergalactic flow yes it was such a
sweet choice because you know the Star
Trek Discovery cast surprised fans at
Hall H with breakfast this morning they
showed up at 6:00 a.m. you have to look
at what they told me the fans
are you it was it was amazing everybody
was so it was so fun they were so alike
some people were like waking up oh hi
Leroy gratitude you know and I was like
it feels so good to pass out sugar
um that cast is out of this world just
fun I love that speaking around this
world we have had a lot of stars coming
to this ET suite this weekend you guys
among them John Cena who is here to
promote bumblebee and even though he was
dressed normally for our interview he's
actually been walking around in
bumblebee cosplay surprising everyone no
one knew it was him see that's how you
do Comicon folks that's how you walk
before exactly that interview and a lot
more have been a streaming live guys our
YouTube channel and we'll be
live-streaming a lot of your interviews
actually the rest of this weekend
saturday is live so Chad we've got all
the CW super shows the flash arrow
coming in we've course got two
interviews with Riverdale getting
excited heard of it osho osho clubbers
are you guys can check out all those
interviews on et's youtube channel right
here but before we go you guys each he
also has a photo booth that all the big
stars have been taking pictures have
been taking the funniest pictures I
think it's time for what you should get
earnest are you doing comic are you guys
thanks for watching
[Music]